Emme G or magneto encephalography has
been used for decades to map brain
function in real-time it does so by
measuring magnetic fields created by
electrical currents in the brain but
conventional machines are large heavy
and require the patient to stay very
still as a result some people can't use
traditional em eg machines like young
children with epilepsy or patients with
tremors caused by a neurodegenerative
diseases like Parkinson's now
researchers have created a scanner that
can be worn like a helmet the advance
comes from new sensors that can work at
room temperature this sheds the bulky
weight of cooling technology required
for the sensors and conventional systems
and the helmet mounted sensors are much
closer to the brain so the signal they
can pick up is greatly increased
researchers demonstrated that they could
measure brain activity while people move
naturally in various ways from drinking
fluids to even playing paddle ball
however the devices sensors only work
when the Earth's magnetic field has been
reduced by a factor of about 50,000 so
the team develops panels consisting of
special electromagnetic coils which
helped to reduce the Earth's magnetic
field around the scanner researchers are
now working to shrink the helmet design
for children and even babies they hope
this technology will be used to better
understand cognition and brain
development leading to more accurate
treatments and earlier diagnosis for all
patients especially those with
neurological neurodegenerative and
mental health conditions
you
[Music]